lefty brett anderson
32 years old his first year with the
brewers good numbers for paul
goldschmidt eight for 15
and two home runs against this
left-hander in his career
both teams really searching for offense
lifted in the air in the gap
in right center will it carry it's off
the wall tommy edmond to third
being waved in by pop warner crow to the
plate is cut off
and paul goldschmidt drives in tommy
edmond here in the first
and it's one to nothing st louis jack
flaherty getting the start tonight
defeated the tigers
game one of a doubleheader last thursday
at busch stadium
there has been no denying the struggle
that that he's had for most of this
season
and that is hit in the air to right
field he hit that one well and that's
the christian yellage
we know and love it's gone and we are
tied in the first
that's why you don't give him days off
you keep him in the lineup when he gets
hot he can carry a
brewers have been waiting a long time
this year for
yellows to carry this offense number 10
on the season for a christian
he takes a curveball and knocks it out
of here into the brewers bullpen
talking about good success against a
pitcher ryan growing against flaherty
amazing numbers seven for 16 three home
runs
three two to ryan braun sends one to
right
center indeed get up get up
it is going to be out of here and
ryan braun has taken flaherty out
and the brewers have the lead
at 2-1 back to back
yelich and ron harris and bader racing
back to the wall made a leaping effort
on that one
it sounded like it was going to go and
it did
when he hit it you knew it had a shot
and now the brewers with an opportunity
to
open it up if vogelback can get a big
hit with two outs and two men on
owners will be on the move payoff pitch
and that's headed to the gap
in left center field that's down yelich
is in
here comes braun he's being waved around
and there will be no throw
two-run double from daniel vogel back
and it's 4-1 brewers
how nice was that finally a big hit with
a man in scoring position
fastball down the middle
and the brewers put up a two spot here
in the third two outs nobody on
a couple of hits and a wall
that's just what the doctor ordered
right here and the brewers have them
loaded with nobody out of the fourth
here is a golden opportunity now for the
brewers to
bust this one open two balls one strike
goes to the breaking ball and it's a
base head into center field
jerk goes in here comes peterson boehner
with the throw
cut off two-run single for novios and
it's six to one bruce
it was off speed took a little off of it
maybe the curve ball and i don't know
is when they bullet into center field so
the brewers now
three for four with runners in score
position early on
yeah great council enjoying it
line drive center field bader coming on
it falls in front of him
another hit for the brewers coming down
to score is orlando arcia
7-1 milwaukee i mean just when you think
the brewers
are going to scuffle offensively and
come up with a performance like this
nice short stroke on a fastball down the
middle and has come to an
early end for jack flaherty as his
troubles against the brewers
continues all the strike to ryan braun
here in the fourth
and a ground ball over to carpenter
there's one and the turn have a pick by
goldschmidt for a double play but
narvaez will score
no rbi but a run nonetheless and it's
8-1 brewers
he is the last brewers player yet to
reach base safely either by hit or by
walk in this game
this one a shot to deep right center
field
back gone casting
hira with an exclamation point in the
fourth inning it's a
seven run fourth
three run home run cast in here he has a
dozen on the season
[Applause]
the brewers brought their bats to the
ballpark tonight
wants to keep going yeah it's 38.
and taylor sends one of the gap in left
center field that's down here comes
peterson rounding third
he will score narvaez to third one
scoring double for jase peterson
and the brewers lead it 12-2
a 3-2 pitch in the ninth
catcher's interference yeah molina got
the worst of it by
far and that's the thing about ryan
braun i mean catchy you can't really
leak that glove out too
quickly uh-oh
molina i mentioned he wasn't happy
before
these guys are going to see a lot of
each other between now and the end of
the season
[Music]
jed jerko you see the former teammate of
molina
now this is not good i mean you can't be
doing this kind of thing
you know kaminsky with the payoff pitch
back up the middle and through a base
hit
taylor is in station to station
otherwise and it's now
14-2
jerko with a fly ball out to right lane
thomas at the track at the wall and he
cannot squeeze it gambles in
it has to be station to station looking
like thomas was there to make the catch
had a little more carry than he thought
just clipped off his glove
[Applause]
2-2 pitch and that'll wrap it up
how about that six strikeouts in two
innings for corey knebel punching out
the side here in the ninth
that's a good inning to a great night
for the milwaukee brewer